foreign
[Music]
a subatomic Universe this judges
everything we know about life Evolution
our place in the galaxy
that guy looks like broccoli
you're an interesting man
Scotland
you're an Avenger
[Music]
you have a daughter
but you've lost a lot of time
like me
we could help each other with that
who are you
I'm the man who can give you the one
thing you want
what's that
I can rewrite existence
and shatter timelines
you cannot trust him I don't care who
this guy is I just lost so much
[Music]
give us a second chance
let me make this easy for you
he will bring me what I need
or everything you call a life will end
may not want her to watch this we had a
deal
you thought you could win
I don't have to win
we both just have to lose
[Music]
I'm sorry Cassie
thank you
[Music]